my name is Doug ray I'm in the school
management and before that and still I
was in the political science department
I'm teaching a course now simultaneously
on capitalism which covers much of the
same material as I'm going to present
this morning i'm going to give you four
slide shows the longest of which has
eight slides actually three slide shows
and one data animation and what we're
going to try to do is begin with the
widest angle of vision namely 12,000
years and look at economic and cultural
events principally in the last three
thousand years that bear on the subject
faith and globalization get clear with
one another about sequences and
periodization then we'll look and that
that'll take us about five minutes ten
minutes then we'll look at something
called Gapminder org how many of you you
have used Gapminder what do you think of
it Hillary oh it was for me somebody
else had their hand up that Stephanie
did you have your hand up it's only been
up two years it's a terrific way of
compressing very complex information and
letting you work with it in a very
active way then we'll we'll finish
actually with two slide shows one of
them about the inheritance of ideas
about economics from the classical world
and from major world faiths particularly
the Abrahamic faiths and then finally
we'll look at
the question of whether economics
conventional economics is pertinent to
understanding the global the process of
globalization and we'll give it a mixed
review so those are a lot of things to
do in 40 minutes let's get started let's
test this
okay there we go so that's what I just
told you so 12,000 years and eight
slides this is scaring me
a whole bunch of information got erased
okay we're going to do what we can the
beginning of settled agriculture is
roughly 10,000 years ago I know that
because other people say it's true I
have no independent confirmation and not
likely to have it and the founding of
the major world faiths is bracketed in
the period roughly a thousand BC 25 70
AD and the coming of the global world is
much later the voyages of exploration in
the 14 and 1500s the emergence of the
modern nation state system who's in
international relations here all right
Ruta are you in this sort of state
theory and all that stuff or not okay if
we start with the Treaty of Westphalia
1648 actually they gooped around with it
for three or four years so there are
several right answers let's let's talk
that through a little bit what what what
war did it end and what's its alleged
significance think probably you have to
shout in when you're in the front row
you're you got to project to those
people
it ended thirty years war about which
was about the netherlands between spain
and germany and it was effectively the
church kind of it was a it was a
decisions rate rise okay it was to
create overarching secular authority
right in the form of nation states and
there had been things that were a lot
like states long before that Rome for
example had most of the properties of a
state or of a super state and certainly
the Greek cities and certainly say the
Tang Dynasty in China there were state
like things but there wasn't a system of
states it turns out that the creation of
the westphalian system of states forms
the grid on which globalization has
developed the principal actors in
globalization are only partly states
they're often companies and faiths and
associations of companies but the the
grid which makes it possible is the
state system and the properties that
states have by definition are two one is
monopoly control of a territory and it
so it needs to be a well defined
territory borders boundaries colors on a
map and and the defining characteristic
of a state as distinct from any other
organization is that it claims the right
to a monopoly on the use of force and
violence within that territory so
Microsoft can do many terrible things to
you one thing it can't do is take you
out in the yard and shoot you states in
principle can do that and states can
states generally well for 12th
functioning states have very carefully
structure
apparatus to prevent the excessive use
of violence but it's always there in the
background so if you any of you get
parking tickets around here that's a
knowing nod angeleka how many you got oh
just two or three you're a [ __ ] how
about you Stephanie seven have you paid
them okay now what if you didn't pay him
what would happen they would find you
find you or find you yeah they would
well they would double and then redouble
each one right and then if you said
screw you they would lock boot your car
and then if you decided you were not
having that and you went and you went
with welding equipment to sever the boot
what would happen then you would be
arrested and what have you said I'm not
being arrested yes and charged with an
additional crime called resisting arrest
and ultimately ultimately if you weren't
compliant you would be put in a jail
cell and that's what we mean that's the
distinctive feature that states have
even the tiniest little rivulet of
authority in a town like New Haven
derive from this massive system which is
the grid work of globalization and which
has enormous importance and
understanding globalization because all
the companies the kind of companies that
fred has been engaged with and is rien
gauging with rely on the ability to
enter into agreements and contracts
which are cross-border and which require
the functioning of a court system which
is unfamiliar
and so there's a world grid of court
systems then at the nether edge of this
there are what are called failed states
states that don't really work right
states that don't have an effective
monopoly enforcement violence going to
be named one Joe Somalia that's perhaps
the most famous others Sierra Leone
others Columbia good Angola yeah that's
enough the point is well and i'll give
you an anecdote there's a very
interesting case where bechtel
corporation entered into an agreement
where they put up a large sum of capital
for the right to operate a water system
in bolivia and they began to charge
market rates that people were not
prepared to pay and in fact couldn't pay
it was stupid pricing but when a mass
rebellion emerged the government of
libya just said sorry guys we can't help
you we can't protect you or your
property Sobek tell package bags left
and lost the money and so that's the
kind of dependence on state system that
i'm trying to sell you the Western
colonial occupation there's a very
bizarre transformation going on between
this monitor and this one with the
colors that's what I that's it's orange
on the screen to match well it
transformed the orange label to green
and so I guess it works this runs about
1500 2 1960 and for a majority of the
world's people the experience of
globalization is rooted in being
governed by outside powers by colonial
powers and the generation of the live
is one or two generations a grandparents
worth more or less south of the moment
of Independence this is the commonest
story there of course places where
independence came say in 1820 with with
the southern cone in in South America
for example but I independence is a
relatively recent experience and
everything hinges on the readapt ation
to functioning as independent societies
now the white curve is you got to
suspend disbelief here a little bit this
is GDP per capita computed from 10,000
BC to the present and the guy who the
guy there's a great scholar fellow named
Angus Madison spelled with 2 d's instead
of 1 and Angus Madison has done these
estimates and they're very responsible
estimates they're not at all precise but
the gist of it is this that taking the
average we're not talking about kings
and queens and aristocrats or Chiefs and
chieftains we are talking about the
general run of people in society
hunter-gatherer societies agricultural
societies whatever have you and the
long-term story is of fluctuation local
variation but the mean stays low even in
the richest societies the curve is about
think of you could think of it as the
90th percentile to the top it stays low
there are fluctuations for example Rome
in its good days a great deal of wealth
Tang China in its high period
quite a lot of wealth but in general no
no widespread affluence which would
begin to compare with the advanced
capitalist economies today and the the
big theorist of this is a guy named
Thomas Malthus who wrote 200 years ago
and malthus's proposition was really
very simple it was this humans
multiplied geometrically if you give
them a food to do it so the curve goes
and agricultural production doesn't have
that property as you pour more and more
labor into a fixed patch of land to
produce food you get diminishing returns
from each added laborer right that makes
the intuitive sense is there anybody
here who for whom that doesn't make any
sense please be frank because it's I'm
not saying anything deep here ok so and
Malta says that it's just basically a
two cylinder motor the model geometric
progression versus arithmetic
progression and the idea is that there
have to be events which which prevent
overpopulation and he sees Wars and
epidemics as such events and if there is
technological progress in a Malthusian
world the effect is not to create
widespread affluence but to create
increased population density so if you
get better at growing grains what that
allows you to do is to have a bigger
cairo than you otherwise would have had
or with Rome Rome used coercive methods
to gather food stuffs
all the whole perimeter of the
Mediterranean and to create in Rome a
city of a million people with an
adequate food supply by pushing down
everywhere else and the single most
important event in the economic side of
what this course is about is the
conclusion of the Malthusian era and the
conclusion of the Malthusian era happens
at different times in different places
we are still in the Malthusian era in
some parts of southern of sub-saharan
Africa in some parts of Latin America in
some parts of Asia but the majority of
the world's people are now leaving the
Malthusian era and people in societies
like our own have been beyond Malthus
now for well over a century more like
two centuries so there is a
transformative set of events that are
very important now I didn't prepare
slides on the demography but let me just
stop and throw this in it'd be worth
your googling this google world
demographic transition and the world the
most important demographic feature of a
Malthusian society is high birth rates
and high death rates people have on
average short lives and the and you
start with high birth rates high death
death rates and then when the transition
starts it is always triggered by the
same thing and that same thing is basic
public hygiene it is sewers and clean
water more than anything else ah and
when you get sewers and clean water the
death rate falls medicine does a little
bit for it too for example the
vaccination
seen for smallpox was important early
and medicine is still important but even
more important than medicine is public
hygiene allowing people to escape the
deadly infections which are caused by
contamination through human waste which
were the leading cause of death for
thousands of years and when the death
rate falls an interesting thing happens
the birth rate doesn't budge this is
true everywhere the first 30 or 50 years
after the death rate tilts down the
birth rate stays high and because the
birth rate stays high the what happens
what would be the logically inescapable
consequence ok I population surge so the
world's population surges from something
like 800 million to something like 6.8
million and the surge happens at
different times in different places
depending on the timing of the
demographic transition but if you want
to ask yourself why is labor so cheap in
many parts of Asia Africa Latin America
and so expensive almost in almost
throughout the northern and western
Europe and North America the answer is
mainly demographic it's not that we are
so much more productive or smarter so we
are more productive because we have more
capital but what we are is scarce ER
labour is relatively scarce in the
countries which are now a hundred or two
hundred years passed the demographic
transition and the countries like Japan
Russia and Italy which are way gone past
equilibrium actually have falling
populations because their death rates
exceed their birth rates which causes
society to age and you have a profound
scarcity of working
aged population so that's an inside now
inequality is where we're going here and
the bottom of the world economy has
stayed pretty flat that is to say
Malthusian and as the bottom stays flat
and the top goes north the vertical
dimension of the global world becomes
overwhelmingly important and so
differences on the order of 10 20 50 to
1 in income per capita mean income per
capita between countries and also within
in between regions within large
countries becomes a principal fact of
globalization I have a piece of fiction
to recommend to those who would like to
explore how that looks at ground level
the fiction is called white tiger it won
the man booker prize a year ago and it's
india seen from the point of view of a
highly intelligent morally flawed in his
own terms half-baked person struggling
to make a living in a market eyes
d'economie where he is one of about 700
million people who just don't cut it in
the way of skills advanced education and
the basis of skills that allow you to be
something other than for example a
chauffeur the terrific book it's it's on
par with Dickens or Zola in their
writings about Europe a century ago so
the consequence of that is that the
ratio of top to bottom gets to be
immensely it gets to be staggering so
that the
the car what whose is this so yours hope
or did it cost $52 there are a billion
people out there for whom that is a
day's income all right so that's just a
huge fact about globalization last slide
of this group in each one of these
societies you have an income curve that
looks like this subsistence on the left
being as wealthy as miroslav on the
right and the curve always looks about
the same the mean varies the skewness
varies but the gist of the curve is
always the same and the American curve
looks a lot like this I could I could
show I've got a slide of it so you've
got a mass of people near the bottom and
an elite minority toward the top and
here's a proposition the minority toward
the top has without exception
disproportionate influence on the
conduct of states there are no
exceptions to that not even Cuba Cuba
has a tiny elite which has access to
hard currencies that no one else in Cuba
has access to and the government is its
personal property or pretty nearly so
this curve is nothing it's nothing
global about this curve it's just it's
just the way it is in each particular
society now hide keynote
now this fellow haunts rustling damn it
Hans Rosling is a Swedish economist kind
of a lefty and he's a data he's created
a data animation which is called
Gapminder yep minor org and you can
change the dimensions but I have it set
up here so that income per person in
logarithmic scale right so it yet it
makes it easier to read by putting it in
logarithmic scale income per person two
hundred dollars a year here forty
thousand here and mirrors rate out here
and life expectancy here and I've set it
to the year 1831 and if you poke around
and ask who are the outliers here you
get the United Kingdom the Netherlands
Germany France the Scandinavian
countries were they were in the debt
they were toward the end of the
demographic transition at this time and
were high side outliers in both
dimensions now let's play a hundred and
seventy years of economic history in 12
seconds the bubbles are proportioned to
the population of a country the big red
one is China the big blue one is India
the middle size yellow one is the USA
I'm going to ask you to give me a
three-sentence summary of what you're
seeing will be a cold call so think
okay Nathaniel you say Nathaniel ornate
okay Nathaniel what do you see ok a
radical increase in the disparities okay
that's that's an interesting point huge
increase in disparities and let's see
people haven't talked to Kathryn what
else okay lagging behind and lagging
behind at a recently increasing rate
right it was with the pack for a while
and then not with the pack it's a really
interesting fact and we've maybe it's
too banal but what's the biggest
generalization you might make about this
how did you say ginia ginia jr e we got
it all now
okay there are actually four exceptions
and they're called the BRIC countries
Brazil Russia India China those are the
surging large systems that have surged
at disproportionate rates in the last
generation and if you wanted to if you
wanted to put the best face on all this
you could say something nice but what
could you say that's nice Alan okay most
of the world is drifting from lower left
toward upper right right sometimes fast
sometimes slow sometimes steadily
sometimes erratically but let's look at
it again and look for that look for that
last point actually started it even
earlier
notice this
that was that was mouth so you've got
what makes global as a globalization
irresistible is that right it is a
general increase in the standard of
living very unevenly shared but
invariably shared in you remember Mike
the income curve with a tail out on the
right in every single country the
decision makers are in the tail out on
the right so a policy that resists the
forces that are pushing things from
lower left toward upper right is not
likely to be embraced by those groups ok
questions on this we've got I want to
save 10 minutes for the other questions
okay let's go back to the slides now
we're going to talk a little about
religion and I'm I speak with great
trepidation my father was a Protestant
clergymen but I am a secular humanist
more than anything else and Miroslav
please correct me if I stray out of
bounds here this is st. oh did you guys
read anything yet or not so you read the
jerry mower okay mostly what i'm doing
here is Jerry Muller okay and I won't
attempt to pronounce a Latin but the
proposition from st. Augustine if one
does not lose the other cannot gain is a
profoundly pessimistic assumption about
the way economic life works and it was
widely shared by the classics by the
Greeks and Romans less by the Romans and
the Greeks but
widely shared and the Abrahamic
religions I think by and large inherited
that belief here's Muller's summary of
the about the Christians the Fathers of
the Church adhered to the classical
assumption that since the material
wealth of humanity was more or less
fixed the gain of some could come only
at the loss at a loss to others did many
of you grow up kind of thinking that the
notion of mutual gain through exchange
is so deeply embedded in our refer back
to miroslava discussion our pleasure
seeking out what was the full phrase
managed pleasure seeking in a society
founded on manage pleasure seeking and
the economist's would just substitute
utility for pleasure utility seeking the
notion that gains from from trade are
possible is wired into everyone I think
anybody not kind of okay
so this is how much I get and that's how
much you get and movements along the
budget line good for you bad for me good
for me bad for you and this is a this is
a common assumption it is foundational
to Marxism incidentally one of the
tricks in Marxism is that the labor
theory of value is a way of
reincarnating this assumption so that
from a Marxist point of view if I
increase our productivity and give you a
higher wage if I'm the capitalist it's a
trick I'm expropriating hours of your
labor because we're on a plane like this
one now the foundational notion of
market societies is you can move the
budget plane out you can increase the
total to be shared and you can do that
for example by loaning money at interest
by practising usury and if there is a
market which pushes money at interest
toward its highest and best uses you can
push the plane faster than if you don't
do that I believe that to be true now
the corollaries of this that have
importance to the faith side of
globalization are these these I'm really
just summarizing Muller here the
prohibition on user he was shared in the
Abrahamic religions the Jews had the the
variant that allowed loans and interest
to non-jews and that difference actually
becomes consequential in European
anti-semitism there's a just price
theory that is implicit in all
of this Muller doesn't make this mistake
it is explicit but it's there the notion
that there is a correct price for a can
of coke zero or a Montblanc pen and if I
manage to Palm it off on you for more
than that price i'm making an ethical
i'm committing an ethical violation or
if you contrive to get it from me for
less than that price you're committing
an ethical violation and that if you
think about it that jibes with the
zero-sum assumption that we discussed a
minute ago labor theory of value is 0 is
in marks and in actually in smith and
ricardo the labor theory of value is the
main labor content is the main
determinant of the just price and again
that's it's not unfair i think to say
that that's wrong but right it you can
say it's right in a normative way if you
want but as a description of how markets
work it's almost invariably wrong
because the capital component including
intellectual capital is just enormously
important the dynamics of European
anti-semitism to pick this up on pages
10 and 11 of Muller anybody recite the
the gist of how that went come on go for
it Stephanie
okay okay perfect and at the same time
they expropriated land land they forbade
Jews to own land so Jews became
relatively specialized in banking
related functions there were some other
functions and when the economy's went
sour blaming the Jews became a dominant
response and that's a pretty important
historical event okay last leg and now
we're going to talk about schumpeter did
you reach from painter he's not a gifted
writer he's a downright van writer but
he is I would I believe Joseph
Schumpeter was the best economist ever
except for Adam Smith and his story is
interesting he is Austrian was a real
banker a real businessman a real
government minister taught in a
provincial University in Austria while
teaching his first year of teaching as a
junior faculty member the library
forbade the distribution of certain
materials to his seminar students and he
challenged the University Librarian to a
duel which he won and I won't
editorialize on that but it's a good
thing he didn't lose because he really
what he really was a great economist he
then went to Harvard and Yale every year
made him an offer it's summer house was
near Yale he's in fact buried right here
but he said no every year what a fool
and champagne at what schumpeter gets is
this this is classic and neoclassical
equilibrium theory about supply demand
and the ideas
markets always are moving toward this
point of equilibrium where the curves
intersect and you get a stable price
outcome and what schumpeter believed and
what Marx believed is that that is a an
ephemeral and evanescent feature of the
way markets really work and the way
markets really work is that there is
always novelty which is disruptive
always novelty which pushes out of
equilibrium let me tell you let's tell
this is a true story tennis rackets for
a for a hundred years or more tennis
rackets were all made about the same way
out of wood laminated wood and there was
great competition within it among three
or four world producers and then what
happened wait who's a tennis player
surely we don't have 25 people without a
tennis player you're a tennis player
okay what's your racket made of aluminum
okay and could you find a wooden racquet
in a museum the only place I've ever
been in the last 20 years where you
could buy one in a retail store was Cuba
they are still making and selling wooden
rackets that's what mar that's what
schumpeter has in mind by creative
destruction somebody finds a new way to
make an old product or a way to make a
new product which completely blows away
the price competition that was going on
in that industry and over and over again
you get violent disruptions of
equilibrium there this is the Santa Fe
Institute Santa Fe Institute did the
following thing ten years ago they got
six of the top 10 or so physicists in
the world
and six of the top economist in the
world and made them spend a week
together talking about their theories
and where'd my books go here we go and
then at the end the guy who was the
spokesman among the physicists said when
the economist's had laid out all their
assumptions said you guys really believe
that the stuff like perfect information
high degree of rational calculation all
that and the Economist backed into a
corner replied yeah but this allows us
to solve those problems if you don't
make these assumptions then you can't do
anything and the physicist came right
back yeah but where does that get you
you're solving the Rob wrong problems if
if it's not reality okay what and what's
really interesting is most of the
equations in conventional neoclassical
economics where do they come from
elementary textbooks in physics they are
the same equations as used in Newtonian
physics because they are equilibrium
theories and they make sense only where
Schumpeter and marks are wrong and I
want to say to you is that shrimp aider
and marks are more often than not right
about the way the global economy
functions marks and it was this that's
not the picture usually see of marks
this is the marks who got that this is
young marks and young marks completely
got that he hadn't gotten all caught up
in that unbelievably convoluted theory
of his he really got this point and if
you read the first 10 or 20 pages of
communist manifesto it reads like an
accurate description of the way the
economy works when he begins to make
prognosis and
terminus tech theories he goes astray
but as young marks really nailed it and
their champagne champagne in addition
was quite a womanizer he used to say is
my ambition to become the greatest
Horseman the greatest economist and the
greatest lover in the Western world I
have so far succeeded on only two counts
he left it for good me to decide he
actually had a 50-year marriage so and
schumpeter has this notion this is that
he this is a way of schema tising it
into into waves of innovation which
where you get to a kind of equilibrium
under given dominant technology and then
a new technology comes along and smacks
it okay miroslav can you get us from
here to what we'll be doing at our next
meeting